Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Deiter and I am a Senior Unreal Engine Instructor
with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series we are going to be taking an introductory look
at how to optimize your Unreal Engine 5 projects no matter which platform you happen
to be using.
We are going to do this by first taking a look at our optimization philosophy or
things to think about regarding optimization as we are building our projects inside of
Unreal Engine 5.
We are then going to take a look at some optimizations that can be applied at our
project setup and then move on to ways to optimize our textures, our static and skeletal
meshes, as well as our materials.
We will then take a look at some of the optimization view modes as well as many
of the optimization tools Unreal Engine 5 provides to help you better understand the
areas of your project that would benefit from optimization.
We've got a lot to go over so let's go ahead and get started with optimization philosophy.